this podcast is brought to you
by
hellotushit.com
father's day is coming i don't know when
the last time
you took a good look at your dad with
his shorts on and you could think to
yourself you know what
my dad's been wearing those shorts for
the last four days i can't even imagine
what his ass host thinks like
you don't need to have those thoughts
anymore not with hello tushy
because they're a portable bidet that
fits right on your toilet
and from now and forever you're going to
fall in love with it
go to hellotushy.com right now and press
in
church and get 10 off delivered right to
your house also
there's a reason i've been telling you
about me undies for months
now that they are simply the softest
most comfortable underwear you'll ever
wear once you try them you won't want to
wear anything else all right do me a
favor get 20 off your first bear plus
free shipping at meundies.com
joey
right now that's meundies.com
joey 20 off
your first pair
meundies.com
slash joey kick that [ __ ] mule lee
here's what i'm talking about
your little midweek finger up to ass
from uncle joey coming at you
nothing like a finger up the ass midweek
to let you know you're slipping
[ __ ]
[Music]
kick that mule league why am i [ __ ]
going deaf here i just need a bag of
mold
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
kick that mule lee bust the speakers i
want to see smoke coming out of the
speakers
[Music]
it's the church of what's happening now
coming at you
june 14th you bad [ __ ] here you
go little young angus for you here we go
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
there you go [ __ ] it's a little
soul stripper for you uncle joey here
it's a beautiful wednesday night my main
man billy herrender is in the house
tonight and my main nephew
mr lee say at the ultimate goomba of
death how are you my friend i'm doing
okay i'm i'm worried about that that
mold you just hate what you think you're
gonna do funny the weed molds every
[ __ ] day you know what i'm saying
are you
is that the first time you've eaten a
moldy edible i guarantee i've eaten a
lot of mold in my day one do you ever
eat bread and midway through the
sandwich
on white bread you're like eating
[ __ ] mold on tuna and you start
getting worried and you're drinking milk
then you can do you eat mold every day i
i hope the thc
burns the mold
or something they entered the
antibiotics in my stomach if not i'll
drink some kombucha juice
and i'll be right back billy orendo
what's happening my brother terrific to
be here i know absolutely i'm happy to
see you and lee and your countenances
up front
this is tremendous absolutely i joined
you guys a while ago on the phone but
uh to be here is extra special thanks
for having me yeah no i've always wanted
to have you on i know billy since uh
1978
which made him uh 11.
in 78 around there 11. if i was 14 i was
headed to a five-star basketball camp
with his older brother
and uh his dad drove us and billy sat
there salivating from the [ __ ] mouth
because we're about to go to [ __ ]
fights how about basketball yeah the
premier basketball camp in the country
you had you be brown out there breaking
it down rick pitino who else was there
that week the guy from the army that's
not friends with shinsula noah oh
yeah way before duke yeah uh who else
the guy that's friends with tinsulo who
coaches texas
texas well shock is smart now but rick
barnes nothing about rick curley head
guy oh tom penders tom petty there you
go yeah
with somebody boston college or
something like that back yeah yeah
that's right he was affordable as well i
think yeah
our counselors were like
roosevelt
dominic what's his name the guy from
atlanta well you know what it was
i'll never forget this when you guys got
back my brother greg says to me goes hey
you know there's this guy
remember the same
dominique wilkins he was on his team
yeah he was on his team
kenny dennard from duke yeah you know
who else cheese johnson
yeah in new mexico state yeah g johnson
you know what cheese johnson's claim to
fame was
the first time they showed bird on
national television you got to cover
them
because oh really yeah because bird was
like division three or something well in
the united states
so in those days they only showed
division one games so here they're like
eight no
i don't know
how to try to know how did that work the
camp because it didn't i mean did the
ncaa change their rules because now
athletes can't make any money no no they
didn't make any money then either they
were just doing it for to be honest
what's that the five-star basketball oh
yeah yeah yeah you go up there as a
counselor and you get exposure because
that guy howie garfinkel who recently
passed away recently yeah he knew
everybody could make the call solve all
your problems oh that's amazing he could
make a call inside
so you had the best college basketball
players in the country and they're free
for free wow no no maybe they just yeah
they didn't get paid well you were there
you know as a as a high school kid you
were there for exposure and for exposure
i was in the house
right so yeah on the way your brother
was a freshman yeah maybe that makes
that major your brother was a freshman
at st peter's prep yeah i was in the
eighth grade
i went to that year i went to five star
booze with rob yeah booze yeah yeah yeah
that was in vineland new jersey yeah
yeah and i went to oh i went to
superstar but i went to the superstar
the year before that was hurley's
campaign yeah i went to the superstar
the year before with uh the kid that
went to boston college from saint from
hudson county oh from rick wynert yes
rick winer went wow
and they both
no corn didn't show but the other guys
both showed the spinach yeah yeah both
showed and uh
it was just a different classic stuff
you know
the the distinction that billy and i
have that lee talks about and
everybody who listens to a podcast has
is that
if you're a certain age
uh
we grew up in the same delicatessen
and that made us brothers
i mean that made us because we were we
it's like family yeah i mean come on
every goddamn day this day and i speak
about them all the time
it's called hash ways and
billy lived right around the corner from
them and there was a basketball court
that belonged to the church
right next to
ashworth yeah yeah exactly it was
wizards
pinball
place we used to buy acid
then it was like uh
hash ways yeah then it was the liquor
store which was always there charlie
chambery frank
ashion yeah worked at the liquor store
right even before
so we grew up you know you went there at
three o'clock and you stayed there till
seven
and in the meantime you drank six cokes
from hash ways there was no bottled
water in those days there's no [ __ ]
bottle there was the iced tea in the
kitchen the iced tea in the container
yeah yeah and you ate a ha ha i was
telling him my favorite
hashtag sandwich was roast beef
with swiss on rye bread with mayonnaise
light salt and pepper [ __ ]
a bag of wise potato chips and a [ __ ]
16 ounce bottle of coca-cola
or i would get the turkey swiss
that was your that was your backup
backup sale turkey swiss
on a [ __ ] baguette
with uh wise potato chips and the whole
jar of peppercinis yeah or there was
another one ham and cheese but then when
i wanted
cross enemy lines and go yeah yeah you
could i think he even went there we had
a friend that owned the funeral parlor
and they had sauce there like oh yeah it
was more like that was before hash ways
got into hot food right you go fifth
avenue you went the fifth and even uh
even uh roses roses remember roses you'd
buy a sandwich lee right it would be
i'll never forget this
you but you would buy a roll and just
the sauce not even the meatballs it was
like 50 cents without the meatballs
probably like a buck 50 with the
meatballs and the other thing is the
classic hashtag story everyone had a
bill so you walk in and on the hit
register there were all the receipts all
the bills were still there right so one
saturday and they were like you know
like these the receipts you're old
school and they'd write your name down
so one day hot august day i go around
the corner and i bump into tommy parker
and he goes bill joe shut me off sky
high he won't serve me anymore my bill's
stupid he goes go and get me a sandwich
and bring it out and put it on your bill
and i'll pay you back i said sure no
problem joe goes what do you want i said
roast beef mustard seeds
i remember that story yeah he wouldn't
give it to you he says get the hell out
of here
just for parker i came out i've never
seen anyone more disappointed because
tommy was deflated that i couldn't get
the sandwich now we had tons of food in
this area
but hash ways was hatchways and hash
ways was hash ways till about seven
years when we shot the
documentary right yeah at the hash ways
and there was no roast beef and i said
[ __ ] this [ __ ] you ruined the
whole trip you ruined the whole trip for
me you think i'm kidding i was like no
rose beef at one o'clock what the [ __ ]
is going on here i've never seen you
complain at like a restaurant before he
like i think you didn't you say
something to someone there or you listen
gary i told you i told him i told him
and now gary died so now i feel [ __ ]
terrible because i made a big deal about
the rosary i just was on a plane for
five hours [ __ ]
one o'clock your mother would be on the
third roast beef by now
and you don't have one out of the oven
yeah i did that once
remember to descose in west new york the
restaurant yeah
so my brother tony loves loves their
muscles right you love their muscles so
i came out to visit him he lived in l.a
he lives out in the desert now right so
he he said okay don't forget the muscles
so i stayed at my buddy frank seattle's
house in jersey city the night before we
left to to come out to la fly from
newark
and we're over dayton ohio
and i said
i forgot the muscles my brother wanted
to throw me out of the house he didn't
want to let me in i told him he was all
fired up and bringing the bus we don't
[ __ ] around
you i don't give a [ __ ] if you better
get back on that [ __ ] plane
and go back and get the [ __ ] muscles
when i first lived in boulder if aaron
aspen
if anybody came to visit me
they had to bring something like don't
come out until yeah like george came out
i made him bring 10 cuban sandwiches
to this day he tells me you don't know
how embarrassing that was walking on
that plane
with those ten cuban sandwiches stinking
up the cuban plate i mean it was
terrible
what do you miss cause we we talk a lot
about food obviously we like chinese
food we like all that stuff what do you
think you miss the most
me yeah
really even though it doesn't exist
anymore i still
it was more
than the food we grew up with them
when you grow up with somebody and you
have tabs
and they know all your creepy [ __ ] you
know because after we got all older
they were still there we we showed up as
innocent kids you know i mean billy was
always a great kid billy got no trouble
but you know we showed up there as young
kids that play basketball and we might
have drank six beers and puked and
and then you know one damn and mr hash
way out there saying i don't know what
happened because we robbed the beer
trucks and they'd pull up to the jewel
you know the liquor store
you know
the worst story ever was the morning i
got up after disappearing for a week
and this drug dealer was chasing me
and i ran the hash ways and that's right
that's right i missed the hatchback went
outside and told him to get the [ __ ] out
of here he took care of it i had rome
thorn i had thorns all over me
because i jumped into our lady of fatima
into the basement and all those roses
were there i got thorns everywhere and
then instead of getting out of there i
kept running in the [ __ ] patch
and i had a thousand thorns on me so i
came out there and i dodged across the
street and ran right to hash ways and
all of a sudden i hear him knocking on
the glass come out here i'm going to
[ __ ] shoot right through the glass mr
ashrae took his apron off he ran out
there he was listening you [ __ ]
i don't know who the [ __ ] you are get
the [ __ ] out of here i call he came in
he went off on me he went off but see
that's the thing is that you hit the
nail on the head it's more than
it was like a happening it was a social
hub
i mean it was
you know the personalities the
characters uh and also the pace you know
there was like a daily like like you'd
walk over there you'd meet in the
morning
and parker would roll and dorito would
walk in and you had your crew that you
walked to school with i'll never forget
tommy parker he worked on that poem from
mrs nass in seventh grade so you went to
harvest man i went to horace mann okay
then you went to the same time then i
went to saint peter's prep like my
brothers my mom sent me down to prep
down at downtown jersey city but walking
with parker i'll never forget he takes
his
notebook out you know i wrote i finished
that poem for mrs nass
i don't remember all the verses but this
verse i remember
clumps of lead
fill this head and soon we all knew
honest abe would be dead
it was like the president's day poem
that parker had right it's tremendous so
parker lived across the street from you
yeah so he's a trophy store right the
drugstore joseph's chose yeah exactly
yeah and then
you would walk up that block you would
meet at hash ways
and then walk to school yeah there was
like that whole daily you know pace of
life and then you'd walk we'd walk
for lunch either the hash ways then this
is in grammar school now or i'll never
forget we would go to white castle where
his mom worked
but we could never get back from one
o'clock the walker was too long you know
what i mean so whenever we were feeling
like really rebellious we'd go to white
castle anyway and roll in at like 12 15
12 20. but a lot of times
we you go to the window you'd order a
cheeseburger an orange soda and a shake
and if the manager wasn't around you
they gave you bags lee so on the way
back you were giving food away even like
you'd curry favor with
whatever teacher was checking you in you
got there a little late with the uh
[ __ ] white castle i can't believe
they let you walk to white castle they
didn't let you they didn't let you well
was it that you were supposed to like
walk home or something like that yeah
you were either gonna go home for lunch
or you could eat lunch at the school and
then play at the playground at the high
school when i was a freshman they let
you out for lunch
then they made a new rule no more
leaving the premises for lunch so you
had to leave out the side door and then
come back to the side door so we had
doors that they wouldn't be monitors at
we knew where there wouldn't be mothers
at and i always went to lunch with brass
which meant that this was somebody's son
somebody who
mattered if they got nailed i got nailed
you ain't playing yeah so i would go out
to lunch with ashley what's going to
happen to me right you know i was
telling these guys you know
we come from a very unique place you
know like it's
it's it's why we're still ticking that's
why we came out here the whole thing
and i still remember
that my sophomore year my my sophomore
year
to massey cadillac yeah was that who was
in
yeah yeah the massey cadillac donated
two
cadillac somethings
two door like the car that
alonzo had in training day
okay i got you that that two car the
two-door
it was something like that
what they did was they put alternate
pedals
and the other side and they gave it to
north bergen high school
as
[Music]
they gave you two cadillacs and then you
had to give it back at the end of the
year the next year to give you another
call that's not the point the point was
that there was a teacher named mr
mcgrath you know he said yeah right
he went to jail correct and i was there
was sean mcgrath too right
yeah yeah yeah mark is a singer
[Laughter]
no it's not gonna pop
it's one of those underground ones i
hate those doctor chinese can't pop this
one what's that chinese woman who pops
pimples on [ __ ] oh pimple popper pimple
papa so
uh mr mcgrath was the driver at and it
started very innocently it started with
three people had to put their name on
the list at 10 o'clock
like if you had gym
to the gym you would drive with mr
mcgrath once a week and it would all
count towards your license
okay so you were three of us would get
in the car with mcgrath
and it started with you going to
white castle and then turning the car
around and you would get in it okay
you'd rotate yeah yeah and then it would
the third driver would end at the
ridgefield circle
and then you turn around on tully avenue
and you drive back to the high school
that's how it started that was the first
month
damn we used to go miss mcgrath you're
hungry
you know i can't stop the car what do
you mean you can't
you can do whatever you want yeah you
got no cops behind you
so we started tormenting and then we
would make him take us
we one day he passed the circle and he
wanted into chan's parking lot so we're
like miss mcgrath
stop the car why hold on and somebody
got out of the car he's like where's he
going hold on he's going to make a phone
call he came out with ribs and [ __ ]
steak on his stick
so after like 10 minutes
finally he ate one of the ribs he's like
okay
so now we had him
so now every day was the same thing
mcgregor let's go up to the chinese
restaurant
now
shifting gear is just a little bit good
you know
coco is very modest with his game
your game was very crafty oh
your hoop game
yeah you know you and parker had similar
games you know kind of like that john
bagley kyrie irving of this year you
know ub brown said that kyrie irving is
the best finisher
in the game best finisher finisher at
the rim and you and parker kind of
shared that in common i remember your
game as being
good ball handler good
feel for the game you were disher you
were a swisher
defender you were hungry
i just want to make sure we talked a
little bit about your game right yeah i
don't want to get out of the parking lot
no no we'll get to that story later yeah
but this went on so it started with then
there's a dairy queen how old is mr
mcgrath do you think mr mcgrath had to
be 50 at the time 48 40.
a trio of a 16 year old would talk him
into going to chance and then there's a
dairy queen right there
so you're
what the [ __ ] we're already here joey we
can't coco you got to stop come on let's
go to dq and we go to dq and get a
[ __ ] mr misty float
and then that went on for like three
months what did like a 15 minute like
two minutes to run and then we eat it
and then we pull over before the school
dump all the evidence and go back to the
school then that start then then it got
to the point we go miss mcgregor forget
chance we get dairy queen let's go get
an eight pack
we get an eight pack of nips you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah this one and once
four of us would drink two
except mr mcgrath so you would split the
third one i mean that's the [ __ ]
we grew up with you know you said
something interesting to me and it's
funny last night as i was getting
dressed to go do comedy i thought you
would mention this about basketball and
i might as well tell you the story since
you mentioned it you know
i was all in bro
i was all in i got hooked on [ __ ]
in the seventh grade and the girl was
supposed to give me a piece of ass at
the end of seventh grade she didn't give
it to me and i fell apart i ended up
going to summer school i was in love
with her she made me come over and dry
hump i just couldn't focus
finally we broke up and i got left back
in the seventh grade
and it was [ __ ] heart-wrenching for
me because i was always an intelligent
guy yeah yeah you know i'm not the i'm
not phi beta kappa but i shouldn't have
gotten left back i always got b's and
a's and [ __ ] i was always the type of
guy just took notes and listened and
so
by the failure that i felt that left
back that year
for me to get everything back i just
dedicated myself to basketball we were
all in 70
my seventh grade year when i got left
back i joined the team finally yeah oh
and [ __ ] seven in north bergen really
me chucky david ruiz i mean these are
guys that can be you got talent yeah
who are you playing
schedule oh you're on the road
yeah you played two you played two teams
you played against three teams
you played the meets twice you played
them once at home once a day yeah yeah
so you had franklin lincoln school which
were all [ __ ]
they went to the games chained up
you know they were coming to the games
with balls on their ankles and [ __ ]
and you had kennedy school and kennedy
school was right where north bergen
talent started ruger was down there yeah
coach picking it and calendrillo down
there that's why they were teammates and
they had somebody else down there they
had three people from the state team
louis cruz maybe greco steve greco yeah
yeah so all those [ __ ] grew up
together down there yeah that's what
nobody knew kennedy school was that
rugar guy who turned out to be gay you
know really yeah even coco espinoza live
like in many ways
is that right that's what i heard they
run a boys club somewhere and uh really
the heart of the country it's a boys
club like a boys club where people go
and play basketball and you shoot arrows
and you [ __ ] whatever it's a boys
club
and then you know elsa
robert fulton too was another one but i
know you said you had the
robert fulton with glen conte archie
manning
and then you had anna klein with del
valle and chuck torro yeah yeah you had
good little [ __ ] yeah so my seventh
grade yeah i was always seven
that made not only did i get led back
but i'm on a team that sucks ass
so dawg i didn't stop
you know
i know for a fact that if you get to
something
and you stick with it
something happens because i did it in
the seventh grade
i went from being a [ __ ] zero i still
remember going to union city
washington school because in those days
you could use addresses
so let's say i was friends with lee and
lee lived in west new york yeah sure
give me your address bro why because i'm
playing for the wreck that's what you
did right you went you went to
competition you know you went everywhere
so i joined union city basketball league
and i will never forget the first time i
joined union city's seventh grade
basketball league was that
robert waters yeah okay yes yeah
and i get kept i kept getting called for
three seconds i don't even know what
three seconds
three seconds i'm like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about i left there and i go
what's a three second violation they're
like you can't stand in the
painted area
i did not know this like that's why i
learned all this [ __ ] so you would just
go to different cities and then on
sundays you take your bicycle and go
down to gilmore school and that's what
dracula played was a cuban kid his name
was dracula that was slam dunkin and
[ __ ] he was just too stupid and mahoney
and all those guys were playing there on
sundays on saturdays naturally you just
got demolished you got your basketball
you put it in your 10 speed in the
middle and you rode your bike on kelly
boulevard 80 [ __ ] miles on saturdays
going from court to court yeah so i
learned how to get good
my seventh grade year i was horrible by
the time i made it to eighth grade i was
starting i was also playing for saint
michael cyo
i also played the 13 to 15 year old
league at horace mann on friday nights
do you know what
i'm in fact lee i got to bring it for
you
before my mom died my godmother told me
to put away a box with everything that
was important to me and i put a trophy
in there
from the 13 to 15 years
but i also put them
my name never came on the paper
never
and one friday in 78 it snowed all week
in north bergen the school system was
completely closed remember this is it
happened in boston too yeah so they
opened up friday night the only thing
that they kept alive
was that basketball league at horace
mann on friday night at six o'clock
because by that time
you know the snow was pretty much gone
and i'll never forget going up there
there was nobody in the stands nobody
dead to get in the bus we'd have 20
people in the stands on friday there was
two games they started at three the
clock kept running yeah yeah there was
no timeout it's that type of [ __ ] no
there were timeouts but the clock ran
running clock running
yeah and we would go there on friday
nights and i'll never forget one friday
night i went bananas
and the next day i'm reading the paper
and i say north bergen 13 year 15 year
old because that everything else was
shut down
there was no basketball game nothing
right the only sports was the 13 the 15
year old league and it was the night i
had 33 points
and it said in the article coco diaz
drills home 33 points
[ __ ] 16 re i did like a moses malone
type
and i cut that article out and leave you
know i still have it i was gonna say i'm
surprised it's not like your facebook
profile picture just like that would i
do something like that one of my [ __ ]
that's my own private so i worked really
hard i worked really my seventh grade
year the year elvis died
i went to uh
i went to while the week elvis died i
was in
superstar basketball camp really yeah
i'll never forget i [ __ ] my father my
stepfather came home
it cost
60 bucks
in those days wow and my stepfather came
home
and i used to rob him from time to time
in those days he'd have a stack of
hundreds in a rubber band
and i [ __ ] timed them perfectly
and he was downstairs he goes get my
cigarettes or something i ran up and i
took 300 bills and then the next morning
i woke up he didn't say nothing even
though he was missing and i go [ __ ] it i
took a number one bus to journal square
i went to that sporting goods in journal
square yeah and i bought some bad ass
limousines for the feet
and i walked with those [ __ ] to
stupid star basketball camp i walked in
put my 60 on the table and said sign me
up and i won outstanding rebound that's
right i remember that because richie
weiner caught coach me
he taught me how to box out jackie
balloon came by
uh
who else was thinking of him when you
were talking about exactly all those
different chords yeah jackie came by
and he taught us and then that was it
i really
i would say in the daytime i would play
at night i read all the books i wanted
to move to french lick
i wanted to [ __ ] uh you know in the
morning in the mornings i get up and i
take 300 jump shots that was the first
thing i did 300 jump shots any court
eight in the morning bam 300 in the
summer wow after the 300 i went home
lifted weights
jumped rope did wall squats i used to
write letters to all the major colleges
to get their training programs bill
foster yes the guy from rutgers james uh
he said what was the the the guy we were
kids james he used to jump bailey james
bailey yes six foot nine i never forget
and then uh i play i played after
mr hurley saw me play basketball at five
star i had
superstar yeah he put me and white on
his aau team that's right yeah and we
sat the bench behind mandy johnson and
all these savages yeah and i'll never
forget we went to play a game and they
lost
and he was so hot mr hurley was furious
we're still in the eighth grade
we're still in north bergen all right
and hurley says uh
he's yelling at his [ __ ] team
you guys [ __ ] embarrass me uh
whatever i don't know bob
venable
yeah remember that name yeah
he was young at them
and all of a sudden he goes i had two
tickets for you guys
to go see michael carr in the garden
tomorrow night against james bailey and
rutgers he goes i'm giving him to the
two visitors they gave the two tickets
no way o'donnell and we went to the
garden the next day we saw michael
corrin out of jersey city number 31
dropping on the lane with phil ford was
one of the guards and [ __ ] yeah it was
[ __ ] mind-boggling like all those
days you know and i have to let people
know this because
this is how much i was into it like i
blacked out everything i just went home
to eat
my mom was mad at me i wouldn't go to
the bar no more and help her my whole
life was basketball
and then uh eighth grade year we went
four and three
at least we were yeah let's get five
yeah you only had seven games that's all
you played with seven games and then
i went to
st michaels did good but we kept losing
the saint augustines they were good they
were always good always you know who the
coach was morel was the coach yeah the
father and the son steve nacho that was
the rest yeah yeah he coached me
yeah but we also were losing to our lady
of
garages all lady of grace
you know broken oh gee we would lose to
them all the time i don't know if
they're still open
and i was just i i it was everything i
knew it was all i knew
see that's the beauty of it that's all
you need it was a ball in your throat
and we had basketball nets every park
had
competition everything every park had
people there you went to i still
remember going up there and that [ __ ]
chucky thomas would school me yeah he
was tough chucky thomas yeah yeah and
hamlet checked the little one and you
guys had chucky thomas was tough
so all those guys i would battle it with
them on those things oh yeah yeah and
then my it was funny i was thinking
about what happened my
so i went to superstar i also went to
willis reed basketball camp really
willis reed had a basketball camp in the
poconos and i think my seventh grade
year i went up there that was a very
interesting camp i also went to football
camp with chucky i went to jonathan he
went to joe namaste
just to learn how to run and stuff like
that sure so i had done all this prep
work i mean i told you calendrillo
called the podcast once and i even
remind them i go one of my
memories that summer that summer was
dedicated just to making freshman
basketball my goal was to start freshman
basketball and if you looked at all the
particulars
i kept coming back to being the small
forward
no matter how you looked at this team
chucky whitey right no matter how you
looked at this team
i still was the small forward
if chucky told now there was a good kid
out of anaheim klein right it was a
couple good kids but i was still an
offensive machine i could really
draymond green yeah position i was in
that position i was in there banging it
you know i went to [ __ ] five-star i
played every day i went to all every
county i rode my bike i ran with a
weighted vest i mean i did it all you
know at night we'd run
me and kathy moran would go to mckinley
and they had that 100 yard [ __ ] thing
and me and kathy moran would time
ourselves doing the 40s and 30s and 20s
and then we would do back and forth to
cincinnati right yeah yeah i mean it was
just doing suicide drills we'd do
suicide drills i mean i worked [ __ ]
hard man i would go up do you remember
the 39th street projects yeah yeah they
used to have a tremendous basketball
it was hidden and it had lights and i
would go there and see sergio badaji
from union city and the other white kid
they had that was tough
you didn't said he had a white kid and
82.
this kid was about a year or two you
ever do the defensive drill against the
wall yeah oh by myself not here not here
no i'm too old to sit there
till you're shaking at night that that
would be the end workout that was it
yeah when i got home at night after i
took a shower and played like i played
bell ball at night yeah but we always
played it
over paul caltos would put speakers in
his window yeah we would play 38th
street park though mrs cardinale would
throw us out yeah and then we go home
take a shower go to the garage take the
weights out and at the end of the day i
lifted did all those biometrics yeah i
jumped rope in the backyard i did all
that [ __ ] i get the freshman year
everybody's telling me
football
you got to play freshman football
because rioton
will only look danny riordan yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i went one damn like i why would i want
to play freshman football
why would i want to do something like
this i played [ __ ] hoops for a year
i've been dreaming about freshman
basketball now you're telling me how to
play freshman for [ __ ] football it's
different seasons though yeah no no it's
still you go right from football to
basketball because football's got to be
over by november 8th or something and
basketball is november 15th you don't
touch the you can't have a coach in the
room to the yeah they just have strict
rules yes they still do but yeah
november 1st is basketball but you can't
have a coach in the room to november
15th
that's when the legit tryouts are and
[ __ ] like that so really on the first
you start going there at 3 30 and
running and playing five on five just by
yourself as a kid yeah as kids but then
on the 15th the coach comes in
and on the 15th i tried out everything
was fine
we scrimmaged in the first scrimmage dog
i didn't start
i it wasn't even that i didn't start
it was i wasn't even playing
i mean never mind nuts okay so i'm not
starting i'll be a great sixth man i'll
learn to live with it
somebody'll break their [ __ ] head and
i'll start
no no i would go to games
and not even play
i mean it was like [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
happened and in practice they couldn't
stop me
really oh yeah the first team in
practice that whole no
no
they couldn't stop me it was like i
don't understand this yeah
i don't understand did the coach just
not like you or something just did not
it just didn't so that was danny reardon
you were playing for he was the freshman
coach there yeah forever
and it's weird i wrote a blog of this
years ago like that that took the win
those things stay with you yeah for sure
for sure
that freshman year that was my big big
big disappointment like
sitting there and watching these
cheerleaders and my friends are coming
to the [ __ ] games going
and i'm like i don't know
and i mean we'd be up by 50 and half the
bench would be in and i'd still be
sitting on the bench like the 12th man
it was an experience i wasn't used to
coach hurley called he's like i hear
you're not starting no bro
it was horrible it was painful it was
just
and i would go to practice and [ __ ] them
up
[ __ ] them up
i mean [ __ ] them up
rebound over them and [ __ ] you
know and it just killed me
it just killed me like i walked off that
that court in february and i was like i
don't know about next year
i don't know
this
you know people were pulling up asking
me what's going on i had people
aspirated
and it just i quit
that was it that cut right through me
that was the
that was strike number one then my mom
died maybe six months after that there
was no coming back and i continued to
play i'd play in hash ways and stuff
like that but just not
just lost it i just lost it
and then about
1998 i was getting high with some people
in north bergen doing [ __ ] i shouldn't
be doing
and at five in the morning somebody i
started playing no at five in the
morning
somebody that was there said hey man
you know we bumped into the party about
a year ago we were talking about you
danny do you remember him like oh yeah
he goes he was talking about how much he
[ __ ] hated you real kid wow
you know he he was kind of racist
there was a part of him that some
spanish people he liked somebody didn't
he just did not like me he doesn't until
today and when this kid told me these
people were telling me the story at the
barbecue he was saying i can't believe
he ever did something with his life
i didn't see him doing anything you know
everybody was bothering me for years he
was saying people bothered me that we
lost that season because i didn't start
you he goes there was no way that kid
was ever going to start on one of my
teams there was no [ __ ] way he just
always didn't like me
and it's funny because when he told me
that for about two years i was like you
know what
i'm gonna go back to north bergen and
light this [ __ ] up one night
find out because he was still doing [ __ ]
at that time he was still doing he was
involved somewhere now he's done he's
retired what would i do kick him in the
cocaine
i'm going to [ __ ] knock his cane down
so that it just uh
it destroyed me i i didn't even know how
to handle at that age like i really did
not know
i didn't cry and nothing i was just in
shock it was like a
like even the older players were coming
to me going what the people on varsity
the people the people who are playing jv
like what the [ __ ]
then the next year there was no
sophomore
team and i have lost my account yeah
something i'm not gonna make jv if i go
to jv that means i'm gonna play against
chucky thomas
i'm not gonna thank chucky thomas i had
a hard time uh forget it well you know
you know what's interesting too is that
that's the phil jackson line there's so
many quotes out there but
he says you know there's more
to
life than basketball but there's more to
basketball than basketball so in other
words you know there are a lot of life
lessons that you learn
from the game both good bad you know
what i mean ups downs
like lou rawls crazy turnarounds lady
love yeah but you know what i mean like
there's so many there's so much that uh
it kind of teaches you and you learn
through these rough experiences i think
that's one of the things about about the
game that's
that's great
but also it can you know it can break
your heart too at the same time you know
what i mean it broke me yeah yeah
that when i played cyo ball
when i played in the eighth grade i
played with frankie winters
wow frankie winters mike hennessey
chucky was an olf guy
yeah yeah sure yeah but white he was
with us and some mahoney played for yeah
yeah and it was funny because i started
in the beginning of the season
and then towards the middle he didn't
like me like uh no i think he didn't
like yeah we were playing teams and he
was like i'd rather have you come off
the bench that was hard to digest yeah
but after a couple games i accepted the
six-man role right like this is right
but then it was right around the
holidays my eighth grade year
it was like the week after christmas
we played the cyo christmas tournament
and we played all g right
and i didn't play the whole game
he played the five guys in the center
and i still never forget rubenacho give
me a ride home
and there was snow out and we're in the
bottom of my hill because you couldn't
go up yeah burning hills in those days
because of all the snow
and i remember on the wall on that
corner i had written my name on the wall
coco 76 yeah 1976.
and we pulled up and i'll never forget
rubinaccio saying to me listen man
tonight was not personal
right right
about the game
he go and he was telling me you know
hennessey's confidence was up but yeah
disguise was down i wanted to switch it
around there was nothing in the next the
last four games i started yeah yeah so
it was it was like a
player thing right yeah well you know
that's going to happen right they're
going to be matched up there's going to
be scenarios somebody's hot somebody's
got the hot hand but a lot of times if
you have
at least that open honest
communication all right you got to live
with it you got to deal with it i dealt
with that i'll never forget that listen
that song was on the radio it was the
hot song don't go crying oh billy joel
billy joe that was the hot song there
yeah yeah and i was in the car with him
and he looked at me as he dropped me off
because you want to walk up to hell yeah
you're gonna get stuck
and steve said listen about tonight
i know you must be hurt and i go i just
didn't know what i did because you
didn't do anything
right yeah i had to match up yeah the
center i forget who the center on that
team was
against that forward because he had
heels he could really jump
and he goes by the time i thought of you
man we were going to lose so i didn't
want to insult you
and but that was the only time in all
those years i had had a problem like i i
digested and i'm like okay doesn't
really matter because i'm starting
freshman year right i mean it was no
matter how you looked at it i was just
my fault yeah yeah i wasn't even close
to that i was like the third [ __ ]
forward on the team he even played
archie manning more than me a skinny
filipino kid from robert fulton that was
uncoordinated as [ __ ] there's a filipino
guy named archie manny manny
and we had a kid named juan rodriguez at
northbrook yeah i remember one well i
was good yeah
yeah
before the kid from philadelphia what's
the kid
the small guy from philadelphia a couple
years ago that had the crossover
iverson before iverson i got to tell you
something yeah i'm telling you this from
yeah 40 years of watching basketball
i have seen some shakes in my life yeah
but one of the best shakes i ever saw in
my life was juan madrid yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah hombre juniors had a shake
move
that you could have your hand on his
waist
and the next thing you know you were six
feet away from him they had more shakes
than carvalho yeah sergio badaji had one
that he would come with the ball and
pick up his legs high
like like machine gun his legs so on the
defense she didn't really know what you
were doing and he would shake you
one shake was a crossover
that he would come down dribbling and
then you would d up on him and he'd wait
for you to put your hands down and he'd
cross over on you real quick but he'd do
this uh he'd do like a rattle like
you're like
lee
it was hysterical to watch
like if you were waiting to play the
next game and there was a fast break
you'd go watch one on this move and juan
would just come down and austin the guy
would d up and next you know he's eight
feet away and he was on the floor
slipping carrying his shoes
he's breaking ankles
he would go like this and then go
like shake like a dancer and you would
just [ __ ] fall apart and god rest his
soul he's dead now but uh we used to
play in lefty cortina's backyard by
robert fulton
brian smythe yeah we used to go to
hoboken in those days and pick up bob
dubose yeah yeah you know what i was
thinking about those when you mentioned
olg i was thinking about those guys
miller
they both played at boston bc yeah
we would pick them up in hoboken and
bring them to north berlin to lefty
cuatina's backyard and we played a whole
afternoon and they'd be slammed duncan i
remember like that's what's unbelievable
too is this that feeling of
like we got to win or we're going to
we're going to be done for the day yeah
we're not going to be able to play
because there's so many guys eight teams
yeah yeah i mean just that intensity was
like an unbelievable feeling you know
what i mean like those are uh
things that definitely i hadn't thought
about that in a while but just that
mentality of like all right well we got
to bring it here we're going to be we're
going to be toast and then people trade
for you and [ __ ] yeah don't [ __ ] you dog
you don't wanna play d [ __ ] you coco's
on that team now [ __ ] that [ __ ] that i
already played three games with you [ __ ]
that and you get done argument you
should have been yeah calling your own
fails you're right the basketball thing
did teach us
a lot of crazy lessons i mean one time
on the bus i fought it
i hadn't gone to the bathroom in like
six days i had like a clog in my [ __ ]
and we played against east orange ghosts
the ghosts was that the aau team or none
of these stars high school this is high
school yeah okay was it the east orange
ghost so the ghost of trying to think
about that the ghost of not
not cleve not it was a black school and
they were called the ghosts that's all i
[ __ ] know and i was scared
that's all i know you know zayn and we
lost to them
and we went on the bus and people were
scared and i hadn't gone to the bathroom
for like three or four days
and i remember farting and cheerleaders
were crying
like they were crying because they
couldn't open the windows and [ __ ]
and then i would switch them up and mr
baron said no he's switching flavors the
girls were holding onto their noses oh
my god
no that was you're right
but that and that was like your coco too
like playing at
prep in jersey city that whole league
was all jersey city league at that time
so you'd play st anthony's it would be
david rivers and kenny wilson
you'd play and they went to notre dame
and villanova and then you played ferris
and daryl wilson went to florida state
and then you play saint mary's there'd
be kenny coleman
uh he played at new haven like hey so
every
every game was like a was like a war you
know what i mean of guys that were
really
talented and i'll never forget the guy
that i had the toughest time guarding
was a guy by the name of tracy mitchell
who played at tcu we were working out up
at umass lowell during the off season so
we come into an open gym
and this guy's out there playing
and i'm playing against this guy and i'm
literally like i gotta guess which way
he's going because he's using me i just
could not stay with him and he ended up
being
like right on the fringe of uh in
today's world he would be like
if he wasn't with the celtics he'd be
with the main red claws he'd be in the d
league you know what i mean he's like on
the fringe like was it was one of the
last cuts like three or four consecutive
years and it's like you know
you get to those moments like and it's
like seeking out the best talent
because you want to get better you want
to raise your game you want to test
yourself and see where you're at and
then you get to a point where it's like
wow
this is definitely a different
this is a different level and uh tracy
was one of the i'm friends with him on
facebook you could find him there and
he's one of these guys that it would be
great because i was big into like like
the gear like the t-shirts and i'd have
shirts and so he would like give me like
tcu gear and i'd give him like
you know i don't know i probably had a
stash of northberg and stuff and my like
a reversible you know we trade all these
jerseys and stuff but
uh
but that was the the beauty of the game
you know the personalities testing
yourself all the traveling bouncing
around did you were you happy that you
went to saint peter's prep or did you
wish you could have gone to north burger
yeah you know because i
i had a great time there and you went to
school with the mafia yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah exactly
so you graduated no no so with frank so
frank was a year older than i was frank
went to prep but mark played at north
bergen then penn state then the packers
so mark went to north bergen high school
frank went to prep and so i had many
mixed emotions about because i had a
great time at prep we had uh
you know like a lot there were a lot of
things that like i probably may not have
been exposed to if i had not gone there
you know maybe i wouldn't have found you
know what probably still would have
played at persian field or ocean avenue
or you know those types of leagues and
and stuff
but
i i think at the time it was probably
the you know the a good fit i played for
jerry halligan who was i mean look at
these choices so it was either playing
for maddie cebello at north bergen who
was an absolute legend
or jerry halligan who was another legend
so you really couldn't go wrong there i
was a fan of sabella what's that i
wasn't a big fan of that yeah i i you
know i really didn't didn't know
coach cebello that well because i didn't
play for him but jerry halligan was like
his face i still remember his little
bald headed
he was like a science teacher a man yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i used to see
him and i was never big cebello guy i
was like yeah
i was a big baron guy you know right
sure he showed me how to shoot
you know i lucked out because he was my
seventh grade teacher
and i went tight when i got left back i
went to his class
he [ __ ] hated me really and he's like
how does it feel how are you going to
feel him sitting in that clay he was
torturing me yeah so i stole his keys
after school
and i threw him in the dumpster behind
mckinley
and about four hours later he shows up
at my house where's my [ __ ] keys i
can't even get my car and i don't know
what the [ __ ] are you talking about see
you in september [ __ ]
and i thought i was gonna go to eighth
grade no i got left back and ended up in
his class wow so when i walked in the
first day of school i thought i was dead
yeah i never mentioned it again
and once i found out he was in the
hall of fame yeah yeah he had done all
that back so the free throws in a row
with 73 or something i wanted no yellow
pages and i would call him up at night
and ask him for tips and he would say
how did you get my number
and i'd call him up until one day he
said come to my house friday at 2. i
took a bus up to 92nd street
and we went to his house and he showed
me how to shoot and we can't i took him
to the premiere grudge match right right
yeah yeah that's all right
yeah so we interviewed them for the yeah
was it the same house documentary he
went to the house was it was the house
no he looked that was his that was his
house we went to his mother's house
like that was my real basketball
was barrow right and then
even if he took over i knew
i just oh yeah yeah you know what's
funny that
you talk about all this stuff being
positive you talk about being negative
since i was a kid i've always been very
honest and i was always very honest with
myself
you know freshman year i think going
into sophomore year i said okay
my father was six four
my mother's five two
you know how tall am i really gonna be
will i be six feet tops let's pretend i
get to be six feet that means i gotta be
one of the quickest [ __ ] guards in
the air yeah now i was always quick but
not fast there's a big [ __ ]
difference
there's a big difference between having
quickness to cover somebody in the paint
or there than me having to catch up to
you once you shake it it's 50 feet wide
94 feet long number two number three i'm
white
you know i had kicks i did have kicks
because i worked at it right right there
was a point where i had like a 40 inch
vertical jump like when i was in the
eighth grade i was already grabbing the
rim at 38th street field like people
going crazy i was missing the dunk by a
[ __ ] [ __ ] here because it was nine
foot the room
but i couldn't you know yeah at least i
could grab the rim out of high school
yeah i was windexing and [ __ ] my
freshman oh yeah yeah that was because
yeah because i [ __ ]
worked on my legs you know what i do i
did the weights bill foster told me i
did the sprints whatever they told me to
do i did to the [ __ ] team
so it was just really weird that i just
said to myself
all i wanted out of basketball
was to play in the national championship
game it's all i ever wanted
my dream was to start it's a big goal
that's great i did not want to go to the
nba i didn't want to do nothing i want
to be like gregory kelser right
who's a great guy by the way that's what
i heard he's a great guy he's he's still
part of the pistons uh broadcast team
he's a great guy because yeah he played
like four games and that was it like he
just
in the in the college he was great but
in the nba he just fell apart you know
that happened sometimes
but that's all i wanted uh from the time
i saw them announce
michael kors freshman year from jersey
city new jersey my head almost exploded
and you know who else was in that game
and our buddy jim hager reminded me of
this one of the last conversations we
had i forgot to mention this guy
marquette and jimmy boylan jimmy boylan
who now is an assistant with the cavs
so he's been he's been with the
cavaliers for jimmy boylan from jersey
city he was another jersey city guy yeah
older than everybody yeah and what do
you play for he play he
so he i think
he went to assumption before marquette
division two school in new england
believe it or not but i want to say that
he played for
rocky pope at hudson like uh
like spinacle did i'm almost positive
that boiling went to uh went to hudson
as well yeah it could be wrong
but you know what i don't want i don't
want to dodge the the north bergen or
prep high school question because i i
really don't know no no
just to complete the thought like it
sometimes it does think of me like
what i think about is it would have been
nice to have continued
the journey in high school with my
grammar school classmates because they
were great kids we had a great cohesive
class but you know my brothers had gone
to prep it was great tradition there it
worked out great for me uh playing gavin
cummings who i mentioned before who had
come over from guyana we played together
uh
four eight years total including the
four at umass lowell uh three on varsity
at prep we played freshman ball together
there and we had three years on varsity
at prep for jerry halligan so i really
wouldn't change your thing but i do
think about
you know because
i made great friends at prep
you know in the classroom and then
in jersey city and and you know around
town as we as you know as you evolve as
a young kid in high school but i do
think about and and you know remiss
slightly about not slightly but miss
just the kids i was tight with because
we probably would have been even tighter
but uh but you know it goes you can't
change it it is what it is what it is
and you kind of follow your
you know your destiny you do what you
think is best that uh
at the time so it's just crazy because
you guys
all grew up together
like i lived in new york until 1973
and then i moved to north bergen in 73
but i was still going to catholic school
in colorado right right yeah so my only
connection to north bergen was the
weekends and the summers yeah it would
disappear right i walked around that
neighborhood when i first moved i'm like
this ain't for me
these [ __ ] dirty kids no no no no no
no no i'm not doing i'll hang out in the
city
i was still a city rat and then i was
and i since my mom had the bar in union
city
i was right in the city yeah i was
living in north bergen i was a union
city kid yeah by 29th street and the
whole thing
right
by the time i went to mckinley
i
didn't i missed what all you guys did
like when did you move to north bergen
oh i was born there okay so i was born
in jersey city did you play peewee
basketball yeah everything from you know
those coaches mr bennett yeah
fisher
all those guys like unbelievable they
still if you go on facebook it's really
weird like the other day
kevin valentine yeah posted
a picture of the football team when he
was like eight
yeah and like
those kids played all through they won a
state championship together
because they've been playing since they
were late
like these guys [ __ ] knew each other
i didn't know that yeah i didn't you
know when i first went to mckinley it
was sixth grade
i didn't even start really hanging out
in northberg until the seventh grade the
first time
first time in seventh grade i didn't
really hang out in north bergen and
that's
and by that time
i was into basketball yeah so i didn't
really play the football thing i didn't
play pw football i played the set they
called it semi-pro
for union city it was 12 to 14 year old
league
and i didn't like it it just wasn't for
me i wanted to play basketball and i was
going to karate and [ __ ]
so
i i would go to those courts
and that's when i started becoming
friends with them but my point is like
you're one of those guys that was there
the whole thing and then just high
school went somewhere else and it just
wasn't you like like you said even
franklin outfield yeah who's tight with
my with mercy's godfather james
you know like he just went to prep one
day yeah but then prep didn't have a
football team well no they did actually
they did yeah
mark go there yeah i don't know i don't
know well you know what like football i
think was different because like north
berger was perennially good and then
prep was down in football they just
weren't very good in the 80s and then
rich hansen came in right around the
time i was leaving and then built that
football program up but they were very
very that's why we didn't know that and
then it was weird because i was
fortunate
because basketball was good then had not
been good in the 70s at prep was good
and it was really good in the 80s and
like you said like so after eight years
with gavin cummings i mean by the time
you know you you play that long together
i mean
you you just have that sixth sense of
where someone is
no no no not even you know offensively
but defensively and all that type of
cohesion and what have you it's uh
you know it's it's tremendous because
it's really a
uh
it takes on a culture a a feel a vibe i
mean look at you know obviously the
warriors right rarified air and how
special they are and watching them play
and like a lot i think a lot of our
people are
if you remember and i was young at the
time but the reminiscent of the knicks
back in the 70s with willis and clyde
and bradley and the busher and you know
all those earl of pearl and all those
guys you know they were ball movement i
don't want to go two x's and o's you're
too much in the weeds lead but you know
i mean just that that whole co-he's and
the defense that those guys play and
that tenacity you know everyone talks
about the warriors and their offense but
that's really
to me their sizzle is the offense but
their defense is
second in defensive rating in the league
and they leave the league field goal
percentage against three-point field
goal percentage against deflections
blocks steals i mean they're just
relentless uh defensive but anyway but
those things take on you know there's
there's more to it
than just the
game plan the execution okay this is
what would but anybody really think
about like
not only they know what they want to do
but then they inculcate it into those
players current staff joy mindfulness
compassion competition and they actually
do it
it's phenomenal i i think you know just
the way they have the the ability to
focus execute get it done but those are
the things that i think that are like
kind of magical about the game you know
i mean it's just that
it takes on a kind of a life on its own
i think that's why we all fall in love
with it you know and you talk about
those kids playing together in north
bergen from 8 on
uh and winning uh eventually a state
championship i mean there's something
really nothing two things in life that a
few things in life that give you that
you know what i mean and then again they
did it with basketball right that core
team played at kennedy school
so i was always wondering like for me i
wasn't part of anything i was part of
mckinley and they didn't have a [ __ ]
legacy they don't even talk about
basketball they didn't even have a gym
so i was in the eighth grade is that
right did you have a gym oh yeah you had
a shower snow well that's how about did
you ever play at white eagle hall
do you talk about not having a ship
saying anthony did i have a gym yes yes
freshman year that's right we played
them freshman year and it was like yeah
and the one basket was nine
unbelievable feet those those battles
were like those were also we talked
about this you'd go in there and play
and at that time for us it was you know
david rivers and kenny wilson those guys
so you'd walk in it'd be massimino with
villanova
digger phelps at notre dame
uh
was it ray uh
al mcguire retired so
not now i'm thinking i'm thinking uh
meyer at depaul but all these coaches
would be these legendary coaches would
be in jersey city and white eagle hall
this you couldn't even shoot from the
corner because it was the balcony from
the bingo hall that you couldn't shoot
yeah you know you you know drive to the
basket and but anyway but evidently they
just
the school is closing at st anthony's
and then uh they actually redid white
eagle hall it's gorgeous now it's like a
real now they're gonna [ __ ] close it
so now they [ __ ] redo it let me give
some shout outs
eric walker my main man you got it
[ __ ] j blank city
dominic giannino
the australian warrior
bunny couch functioning savage my man
ray taylor slim shabby
tony mendoza and ty moore
i gotta ask you some other questions
yeah i'm gonna ask you some questions
about the characters
that hang out about hashtags to see if
you remember yeah
i always tell by lee whenever we're
talking in conversation
and he says something to me i'll go
leave it that thing is clean bobby
and there were these two idiots that
used to hang out at hashway at night
one was chicha by steech he was a short
guy that fixed cars and the other guy
was bobby pierce
he had glasses he used to have like a
what do you call that when you have a
ninja would you have a
cleft lip a cleft lip
really yeah he used to so they were in
the car
he used to go that thing clean bobby
they would just sit there and that thing
clean that thing clean bobby that thing
clean
you know i think about
the characters we grew up before the
show started we were talking about just
that area okay just that
it was hashways that ran and it was a
block away from north bergen high school
and on that block when i first got there
there was a a grocer not a grocery store
like a food store around the corner like
where you went for milkshakes yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's right yeah the brewing
bowl yeah that's right that's right you
had nyx pizza and then you had corky's
seven day week it was called tom and
corky's then you had a bank that was the
size of a hut that was robbed once by a
guy on a bicycle and he got away with it
they weren't even prepared for him
to rob the [ __ ] bicycle then you
crossed the street and there was a dry
cleaner
and then you walked a little bit and
there was a bar
that had been everything lee they tried
to do
everything in this bar then next to the
bar was a trophy sneaker place
oh yeah you know it was broward dennis
brower had that it was it was like it
was like a sporting goods yeah that was
never yeah yeah yeah it was never open
it was only open like one hour a day
they sold sneakers right you got a good
deal on sneakers yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then next time there was a
pharmacy and then it was larry ld there
was a hair cutting place there but
that's a barber shop larry yeah and that
was all there that was it that was your
[ __ ] world if you looked up there
that was it he went from the bank but we
grew up at this pizza place that the guy
was [ __ ] like the guy
in today's society with kids he would
have definitely been shut down
he would have definitely been shut down
because it wasn't about even like that
he cursed him no no it wasn't that the
pizza was bad the pizza was delicious
and the sandwich yeah oh my gosh
tremendous yeah it's tremendous hot see
hash ways had cold sandwiches they had
hot sandwiches at night like a chicken
cutlet oh he had a field he had like a
he had something in that a next meatball
parm or something you get two slices and
the next meatball part oh my god and you
can put it on the tab because everybody
at a time those days he'd call you he'd
call you like
racist names but then he'd give you a
tab he gave you a tap [ __ ] he'd extend
credit [ __ ] speak i'm watching you
he called me the [ __ ] a villa ayatollah
khomeini are you told cause he had the
beard so he would make you make me
nervous
you walk around ali atolla holmani he
would call him homany
he would call me the [ __ ] venery the
jew
because he would get the iced tea across
the street i mean it was [ __ ]
constant the nicknames he had for people
sexy thing beautiful thing
for women oh i love you
but he never was a pervert or nothing
like that what he was was a degenerate
horse yeah yeah you look at the ponies
he loved the ponies and you'd be hungry
some afternoons and you'd go there let's
be
gone close for one hour he would just
shoot to the track yeah oh yeah exactly
yeah all his horses at four you'd be
[ __ ] starving after school you're
like god damn it i gotta go to hatchways
together and [ __ ] and that's like uh i i
told you john bott we're gonna give john
bought a shout out a sing donut he said
tommy parker wrote two words in my high
school yearbook pacing doughnut it was a
horse that is a gamble made now no no
nothing nothing no
i was gonna ask what was it like because
we've heard all the stories from joey
about what north like north bergen
sounds like almost like like it's not
even real like it's like an acidity of
outlaws what was it like growing up as a
kid who like
i wasn't an athlete but seems like me
like a little bit of straight edge and
sort of not as crazy as them like what
was it like was everyone like that or
was there people there who
no i was i mean i think it was a very
like
eclectic group of people you know what i
mean that
you know not i don't think everybody was
like that you know what i mean like it
was just
uh
you know like
basketball i think sports in a way was
kind of an escape
it you know was it was your identity
probably to a uh
to an extreme you know because you were
only as good as your last game it wasn't
tough if you weren't playing or you know
we talked about that earlier if you
didn't play well it was hard that was
your identity but there were just the
cast of characters there and but i i do
think though that you thought every
place else was like that
so you'd go to jersey city and different
neighborhoods yeah it was like that yes
but then when you leave and you get out
of there you're like holy [ __ ] oh my god
not not every place is like this you
know you go to new england right exactly
yeah but no growing up you were in there
and it was you're right you had uh
a couple of bucks it was a quarter for
an rc probably 35 for an hour 45 cents
for this i had the [ __ ] company
antonio avenue honestly if you went down
there and knocked on the door they give
you three soldiers for a quarter
rc they made them run antonio
yeah they bottled them right there on
the corner there so we were kids they
were that by my house we had the
danon yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they
had the tea company so well how about
hoboken with it with uh maxwell house
yeah you could then be brewing coffee
the whole city would smell like coffee
yeah but but that was like all you
needed was a ball
like a buck because you get a slice of
pizza and knicks for 45 cents and that's
all that was your life that's all you
all you needed you walk around the
corner you're at the courts everybody's
there hanging out so it was it was an
unbelievable place to grow up it was
tremendous it was great i uh
but but i think that
uh
you know if you looked at it you
probably had
you know guys that were into sports guys
that they were into music guys that went
to
girls guys that were right now where
were you when hatchway's burnt down
were you on kelly boulevard were you
around the corner i don't think i was
living there at the time i was in school
i think it was 1984. yeah i was at you
know you know what i was at umass lowell
it was my freshman year so i was not
we were in north berwick we went to uh
you know the town that that i left
i left in august 25th
of 83
i left
and i went to colorado and i came back
like february of 84
and the town was completely different
it was just a drug death
huh that's it the cocaine from west new
york union city
it had just taken over i mean there was
there was a rest on 80th street by
lubz's house
by johnny what was those two spent lopez
brothers yeah they were [ __ ] out of
their mind those two luckily
they used to sell their mother's cancer
medication
they used to drive around shooting cats
and dogs it was [ __ ] crazy down on
that side
but all those houses were getting it was
just a different city you know and
everybody was [ __ ] doing drugs like
it just
you know you walked into ashley's next
you know you're in the freezer doing
coke
you know you're like what the [ __ ] i
used to come here to eat i don't even
eat here no more coming in and do coke
and drink champagne
and uh why do they have champagne in a
deli because at that time
they had a liquor store right right they
moved over see they had a sandwich place
i was telling i was telling
billy that
i could you know how fx does american
crime stories or american horror stories
right yeah i could do a whole
story about life about the hashways
because they had a deli
and the deli was doing just fine
turkey sandwiches roast beef fresh roast
beef fresh turkey
you who's you know
buttered roll which was delicious yeah
yeah
the jelly and cream cheese on the poppy
seed roll
was delicious but you who in the morning
and they got greedy there was a liquor
store on the corner
and they bought into that liquor store
you learned from watching in your life i
learned the big lesson from that
be happy with what god gave you
you had a beautiful deli they were i was
telling
billy that at three o'clock
the father would run the lunchtime
deposit at one o'clock right across the
street to the bank
but at about four or four thirty he
would walk home with a brown sack filled
to the gills
filled to the gills they were making
money there guys
i mean when you went in there at lunch
time and all of you were gone and mrs
ashford give me a case and go restock it
for me
that's a case of [ __ ] news they sold
already during lunch
they would sell sandwiches i mean you go
in there the shredded lettuce if you
think of anything that stood out
it was that shredded lettuce would stick
out of the sandwich and you people think
we're crazy here you know lee knows how
much of a fanatic i am about food and
how loyal i am and how
you know for years i didn't eat
sandwiches when i left north bergen
like nothing would measure
nothing and it was such a simple
sandwich
roast the roast beef there she made it
fresh
not with humans not boy's head
she bought it every night took that rope
off when she got home from work at five
o'clock when she got home from the deli
the deli stayed up until nine when they
got home at five they would start
cooking for the next day
wow and we had a relationship with the
hashways yeah you had a relationship
like nobody this is why we know
everything about them so i i i would go
my mom would send me over with like my
mom would cook like pot roast at home or
something and she would send me over
there and and ann or joe would slice her
pot roast right and then and i'd take it
home and then i would feel so guilty i'd
walk in i can remember walking in and
joe would be cleaning the slicer
and i'd be walking in like he's ready to
go home and he always would take it
always would take it even though he was
like you know one foot out the door
ready to i mean just unbelievable like
we said like family you know uh
obviously yeah yeah but once they took
over that liquor store in 84
everything changed drugs was feeling
them
it was if you went in there at eight
o'clock at night
you couldn't it was a [ __ ] it was
crazy
it was crazy
there'd be 15 people in there coked up
to the gills and people coming in buying
lottery tickets
because they bought lottery tickets and
booze and you'd still it was
embarrassing
and we'd all go up there and help him
the quicker he stocked the shelves
the quicker we'd go out and party
so 10 of us would go up there and stock
every [ __ ] shelf in 10 minutes all
the beers all the booze and we sweep
let's get the [ __ ] out of here so we go
party
and it got so bad by the end of 84 that
summer
that town was in that rhaegos walking
around with a microwave oven to cook
cocaine and a in a bazooka i mean
everybody was going off and by that time
it was coming in
in more abundance that you were snorting
so people were giving it to you on
credit which made the situation even
worse
so we all went to a place called the
maikai yeah oh i remember the kennedy
boulevard i remember that
yes they got close shut down for uh
selling cat
and for uh using the grass from the
cemetery
for what what were they using grass for
you know when you go to the dish and
they have all that grass
no they like lettuce and all that [ __ ]
oh
they were come on the lawn at the at the
cemetery and sprinkling on your [ __ ]
food and [ __ ] how's that for you they
found a bunch of cats and lizards and
[ __ ] iguanas and
it was crazy we would go there first in
11 and drink a couple zombies and get
[ __ ] up
and then we'd shoot out to a giant game
and get more [ __ ] up at the giant game
and then we'd shoot the [ __ ] corkies
at about six or seven and it was it
that was it he had two dollar bluebirds
which was bluebird orange juice bluebird
orange juice with uh smearing off vodka
something
two dollars a piece
you know he was a nice boy billy
herrender we get the hash we get to
we get the corkis on this beautiful
sunday had to be like sunday
if you look at the lineup look at the uh
look at the giants 1984
winter schedule for football it was like
september 25th
1984 when they played the tampa bay
buccaneers
and [ __ ] that linebacker that running
back
he was the healey
james wilder oh okay
james wow so what do you want to know
well the day they've had they they lost
the buccaneers yeah november 11th of 84.
well it was november 11 [ __ ] i thought
it was september 23rd
it was november 11th
no oh oh no they did i'm not i'm sorry
they played twice
what was the first time september 23rd
you're absolutely right you see what i'm
saying though you see i'm saying dawg
you see i'm saying dog you can't pull
one over on uncle joey because i never
forgot that date because from there we
went to ash we went to
corkies and hatchways was closed on
sunday
and all of a sudden we're in corki's
getting [ __ ] up
at six o'clock in the afternoon and also
you hear fire trucks pulling up
and we're like what the [ __ ]
and austin they're kicking down the door
at ashways and they're going in there
and the windows are burning and what the
[ __ ] and we're all outside and people
were crying
i mean people [ __ ] drove up there
yeah yeah
because i remember my mom calling me and
tell me about it because i was up at
school yeah and it burnt down to the
[ __ ] crisp
it took a couple months to reopen yeah
you know yep yeah and i'll never forget
that years later they said that uh one
of the brothers was downstairs smoking
crack did you know that story
you heard something
yeah
[ __ ] hilarious only in north bergen
he put the crack pipe
he was smoking crack downstairs
and also he heard something as you do
huh he heard something and he put the
crack pipe down
and he walked to see what it was in the
crack pipe like the wind gun or
something like this this is the story i
heard the
the torch fell over
and the torch burnt something that's and
then north bergen covered it up and
they said it was an electrical fire or
something that's what the word was on
the street only in north bergen can you
hear something so funny that was
that was the thing about my hometown
that you said something beautiful
tonight billy you said that when you
leave north bergen
you expect that every place is like
north bergen and that's the same thing
that happened to me
i thought that when i left north bergen
people gonna be like that i thought that
everybody had the same mindset
as we had i thought that
you know i'm very proud to come from
there because i came from that a time
when you don't have earrings
near do i
you don't have any tattoos i don't have
any tattoos
you know if you see the kids from that
generation we didn't fall for anything
we didn't
we didn't fall for anything i mean we
fell
for nothing we fell for drugs you know
not not you and your brother
but you know if everybody's like this in
north korea nobody
was into tattoos at that time you
couldn't really have long hair
they were like these little unspoken
type rules that if you want to get yeah
yeah yeah this is what's going to work
bro
you know and i got it at an early age
you know when they got you a job you
worked hard like that yeah yeah little
north bergen just see the program you
get a job there yeah yeah absolutely
it is you know like
i remember asking uh
mike ronnie's nephew when he came out he
was in the navy and he came up to spend
the week on me and i go so how was
hashways growing up and he goes i never
rated ashley's growing up and my heart
broke
like you grew up
next to one of the greatest delis that
you'll ever eat on in your life
the only thing they didn't have
that i didn't care was wet mozzarella
oh yeah yeah it's interesting they never
had wet lunch they never really had that
hard bread
i would go up to the place on 91st
street which is still there not roma but
the other place that was there for three
dollars in those days they gave you a
sandwich lee
lee me and you cannot finish it no way
three dollars lee
no way me and mike ronnie cannot finish
it ponte corvo no no no no no no on top
of 91st street
on top of 91st street by the gas station
yeah
right across the street they used to be
an italian deli they made an italian
sandwich for three dollars lee in 1982
you could not finish
stacked
wet much salami from uh kabal [ __ ]
uh the other [ __ ] that the prosciutto
ham provolone two types of cheese
lettuce vinegar oil olives you couldn't
finish it jesus and then
the palmers the palmers yeah the palmers
then you had roma pizza which was
[ __ ] true it's tremendous yeah they
used to have the stromboli dog that if
you'd eat that [ __ ] in vegas your head
would blow up in the water in north
bergen they used to
also make a shrimp parmesan sandwich
they used to all then you go down from
then there was other kid soul pizzeria
joey returned
his dad phil and his mom phil tremendous
pizza tremendous pizza we were blessed
with tremendous pizza this is why i am
the way i am lee
this is why i'm the way i am you know
see that's the comment to me that's the
common denominator like a fancy word for
it would be uh
authenticity but people are just real
and i think the reason why
there's a
such a strong bond and love for you
is just because you're real
uh and there's just a
a toughness
about people i think that we grew up
with like a resiliency like a uh
like a fire
that everyone
had and has and has just kind of
channeled it in whatever they were
passionate about you know what i mean
that's a habit you have to have that
passion
or if not you could eat now you get yeah
and you get left behind
yeah yeah there's something weird
like i see the kids i grew up with now
like venery me you oh none of us have
tattoos
we wouldn't even think about it like
that would just be no no no bueno
like nobody really had long hair we just
you know these kids were not were
[ __ ] athletes
like that was the only dropout these
guys were athletes
and they still smoked a little pond they
still drank and they still robbed beer
trucks you know where we came from jocks
had a different
jocks were like a little bit [ __ ] a
little crazier a little bit on the crazy
side
but i thank myself every day for being
from northbrook yeah new jersey and i
think the other thing too was like i was
very very thankful to like the older
guys because they would always look out
for you you know what i mean like you
just got like vic saletti we talked a
little bit about like jimmy miller and
those guys at blitz offered down 82nd
street
they would like look out for you so like
and with my brothers i never
you know i just got squashed i never
really had the opportunity to get too
far off the rails not to mention my
mother who was you know rock or
gibraltar i mean there was no i was not
gonna
get too far out of line because you know
he's had a great family great support
system great friends but the older guys
in the neighborhood really looked out
for you i think and they
you know they just you know they cared
enough
to uh
to you know kind of just keep you and
keep you in line
it's crazy how
i look at you and if i close my eyes i
could still see you with the basketball
with the shorts on
playing the ball between your legs
calling us all out who wants some you
know
who's going to get some of this today
who wants it you and
bothering us and [ __ ] like trying to
[ __ ] break up balls we talked about
the high archer by parker yeah the high
occupied it was just uh
it was such an innocent time you know
and uh
i go when i used to go back i would call
all everybody and say look
i get in that one i'll meet you at
at 3 30.
and i'd meet 15 people in one shot done
i'd kill every bird with one stone they
tell all your stories
you eat your little ham and cheese
sandwich you get your little rice
pudding lee they had a rice pudding
that was
phenomenal
i love the rice pudding and i turned
rafi may on to the right pudding
and ralphie may would fly in newark and
just go get rice pudding by the tub
they would make rice raffia made the
whole tray
of [ __ ] rice but it was delicious
with the cinnamon and the [ __ ]
whipped cream you could you never had
better rice pudding than that the
macaroni salad was to die for yeah the
potato salad was to die for you know
what my wife loved was the seafood salad
i like the tuna okay yeah here's my
question about the tuna did they put
anything in it like celery or weird
okay i can
no no that's how you know it's a good
place i hate that i would watch her in
the mornings
she'd empty the tuna and she'd break it
all by hand
and then she put the mayonnaise a little
salt and pepper
and she'd give it to you by the cup
so you get a medium cup of tuna or a
large cup of tuna and he tuna he didn't
have to eat the bread she was 20 years
ahead of the game
way before the [ __ ] cubs
no i uh
that was my problem
and that's why i think i gained
i never talked about these stories
because i thought everybody had them
right right when i left north park and
i'm like okay
so who gives a [ __ ] ah
but i never forget one time when i was
growing up i was at a friend's house
that he had a reputation for being a big
party guy
it was that winter 84 when north bergen
was just going nuts
and i'll never forget this scene we were
in this basement it was a sunday night
there had to be
20 north bergen kids in there and you'd
think it was friday night at 8 o'clock
and these guys had all been going strong
since friday same clothes they had been
the city
and i'll never forget that these kids
walked in there they came with somebody
from northbrook and i forget who brought
them
there were three kids from cliffside
park
and they came they showed up at like
four
and they were like yeah we want to drink
with you and it was a great time but
there was somebody in that room that
kept taking out packages of drugs
and finally one of the kids from
cliffside looked at the other two and he
goes
we have to get out of here like these
guys are just crazy
and they left and everybody started
laughing like it was a scene from a
biker movie like they really ran out of
it like this is just too crazy
and i always sat there going you know
is it us i mean what was it that was
there something in the water that made
this crazy
i still remember one halloween when
everybody showed up with animals
okay
i was caught i got a call like at eight
o'clock
that we were going to this [ __ ]
halloween party dressed as garbage
to just show up behind the high school
at 6 30
that they had cut the bottoms out of
garbage cans
and you had a they put suspenders on the
garbage cans so you had to wear shorts
and put the garbage can over you and
then get a bag a brown bag we got from
hash ways and we crazy glued it to the
top of the tin
so you could put the glue on the cap on
your head and you had a garbage can on
your head
and then we took the strings
and somebody went to the pet shop and
got like 30 mice
and we took strings
and we tied the tails of mice
every kid does this listen to this and
we tied the other end to the top oh so
you were walking around and the mice
were hanging off your garbage can yeah
just by the tails fun biting down like
10 of us showed up at this halloween
party with these garbage cans on dressed
as garbage with actual spaghetti boxes
in this from hash ways we all took all
the boxes and we didn't stink like
garbage or anything we just were dressed
like garbage
so
somebody [ __ ] i think it was mike
ronnie this is my sock it was my junior
year
i think it was mike running in front of
all these kids
got up on the stage without saying a
word
i'll never forget this is playing this
day all you know how kids are like ha ha
ha ha he's like oh
you look great it was a halloween thing
and this kid got up and he goes hey and
everybody turned around he took the
first string
and he took the mouse like this he
opened his mouth
and he dropped that mouth that mouse in
his mouth
and he bit that [ __ ] thing in half
and blood squirted out of his face
and you heard people puking girls were
yelling and [ __ ]
i still remember hearing the girls just
losing
like this yelling screaming those whims
and all of a sudden everybody at the
same time took those mice and started
biting that no no no no yes we did and
we started i bit that mouse height off
and i spit that head up into the air i
could taste the blood oh my god it was
[ __ ] horrible i'm surprised i'm not
dead today from doing that [ __ ]
and a bunch of them were eating the
[ __ ] mice they were taking their
heads off the floor and chewing on the
heads it was terrible
it's because you got that mold
he's going to be fine
like for a year or two oh my god a bunch
of those idiots were eating [ __ ] at
parties
so they would go to parties and take a
bottle and break it with a hammer and
start eating the glass at the party
somebody saw
somebody eat a bicycle on david
letterman in those days
and they wanted to eat a [ __ ] bicycle
i mean these guys are crazy
you have no
[ __ ] ideally i'm surprised if anyone
even brought like one mouse into like my
high school dance like they would have
made it like three feet they would have
been tackled by
by the by like the janitor or something
like he bit that [ __ ] mouse's head
off what do you mean you can't just say
him now you just said everyone did no
but the first guy they did
when he bit that [ __ ] head off and
that blood squirted out of his mouth
you thought godzilla was in town even
the teachers were yelling they didn't
know what to think the poor teachers in
the high school didn't know it that's
why i'm saying
that your mom was like your mom was like
listen i gotta ashwagandha i know what
goes into the high school i can't have
you go over there those kids are [ __ ]
animals do you think you like ruin the
careers of any teachers like they left
like they were like 26 and had like full
of hope and they had you guys for like a
year or two and then they they left the
teaching profession
you must have just destroyed when i was
in grammar school i went to grammar
school with pretty much civilized
animals
mckinley school because it had the
people from 26th street park yeah and
they had like nuclear waste over there
under those buildings something was over
there
that [ __ ] those kids up let me tell
you something
in those days north bergen had a thing
that if you were 16 and you were in the
seventh grade
they had to automatically put you in the
pilot program and you went to high
school you're 16 in the seventh grade i
liked it that happened so often that
they had a rule about it because spanish
kids came from cuban they couldn't speak
the language okay so until they couldn't
figure out the english they would leave
them back
so they were leaving back for three
[ __ ] years these kids were they yeah
when i got to the eighth grade there was
a kid named peter jimenez
he was like 16 and eight in the seventh
grade he had a beard
he had a mustache he drove his sister to
school every day like a driver's permit
you [ __ ]
you know it was it was
mckinley for me when i left sacred heart
school for boys
was a complete
360.
like i had never seen that even in new
york city i went to school bs 166. i was
a little on the young side i was only in
the third grade if anybody was doing
anything bad it was me in those days
they got thrown out of there because i
was stealing the teachers edition
and selling them to other students
for the small two dollars and [ __ ] but
when i went to mckinley
that was
my three years at mckinley i could write
a book about it yeah i'm sure you could
i saw louis alvarez punch leo gatoni
right in the [ __ ] face i saw an
eighth grader punch the principal of the
school
in the eighth grade and almost knocked
him out that the principal took like
three steps and he he graduated in fact
he's still on my he's my facebook friend
louis zelda
i saw
a parent beat the [ __ ] out of a teacher
at that school
i mean at three o'clock i saw a teacher
got arrested
at that school he ended up going to
prison for like seven years for [ __ ]
the mayor of weehawken i just had a
you have no [ __ ] idea jesus christ
i don't that's
no this is crazy mckinley school
was completely crazy then i ran into
carmel in balzano
and he beat up the teacher they beat up
the teacher twice
this was a [ __ ]
a western this was a wild wild west type
[ __ ] production
and and like knowing
because you would go to new york and you
would see so you were just around
craziness all the time like all the time
oh all the time
all the time at that
and the people you know it was just
weird i quit karate
and i went with the circle
karate before basketball i was thinking
about that karate was
during basketball and the main reason
why i quit
karate was for basketball i quit karate
in the eighth grade wow so i could be
ready for freshman year i didn't want to
bother i didn't want to [ __ ] torture
me
so you were you were like kind of an
athlete yes
but even though i was considered a jock
i was still a druggie
i was still crazy we weren't jocks like
the ordinary jocks that's what
blew your mind we weren't jocks like
ordinary jobs
we were jocks that were also junkies
and everybody knew it that we were
smoking pot and doing acid and
doing thc crystal we were taking it
[ __ ] deep and am i proud of this no i
was a dumb kid
i can't i mean it's just it actually
there's no it doesn't i can't even
relate to it at 15 16
i don't think i had my first like like
smoke of like a joint until i was 18 i
think
i drank a little bit in high school but
barely
you know i i wanted to bring uh
billy on just to show you
that there was also
decent people in bulk bargain also you
know they weren't just [ __ ] animals
that uh
you know we weren't just animals i mean
but you know what like there are things
that happen that like you almost forget
about like i can remember a fight
breaking out one day and i was like
about 11 on my corner
and uh
yeah one thing leads to another and a
guy he's got another guy on the ground
he's got a knife to his neck
so it's like you know like some of those
things you remember because
you know you probably maybe you've never
heard someone scream for their life but
that that that creates like a a searing
memory you know what i mean that
but again that was
luckily it didn't escalate after that
let him go and the whole bit but you
kind of just kind of roll with it
but it was uh
you know it was never a dull moment
that's for sure it was very educational
and it's uh
i think that the
i mean you ended up becoming what you do
i think it has a lot to do right no no
yeah yeah yeah all of life life's
lessons like you described that couple
but okay listen whether you go from 91st
street down to 6th street
or if you go from 76 to 79th all
all of life lessons are right there they
were they were really right there it's
true very true
it's funny how if i think about stand-up
comedy
i think about freshman basketball
getting on the number one bus
and
just tormenting that poor bus driver
from the minute you get on that bus on
79th street
you start singing the odd couple and
[ __ ] the honeymooners
and by the time you get to 50th street
he actually pulls over and goes you guys
are knocking off
or they're going to throw you off the
bus and then the second place the early
roots economy were right in front of
hash ways right right in front of that
you know with eight other funny people
that wasn't crammed in driving that
number one no no no
it was just really weird how those
my lessons in front of that deli
are standing in front of there cracking
jokes you know like
just uh
it's who i am today yeah it really
you know i'm into food because of that
deli
i'll argue to the debt with anybody
and i'll bring back up and we'll win any
argument with that deli because
that deli was more than good it was who
we were like i said earlier it was
our identity you know
tabs right nobody's got that but yeah
and the other thing coco that maybe
you're overlooked because you're too
close to it is the uh
like
just the co the art of conversation
and like you know what i mean like that
somehow everybody i'm as guilty as
anybody you're on your phone you're
texting like parker says to me every now
and then enough with the texting it'll
pick up the phone and call but you know
like i think there you really learned
how to how to socialize how to uh you
know bridge gaps whether it was you know
uh
spanish people black people people that
were different than you older people
younger people you know what i mean like
i felt like it really stretched your
horizons
uh
and you learned how to how to get along
basically pretty funny interesting you
said that
i won't take a tax from nobody from
north america
you want yeah i noticed that you're not
a bit yeah yeah
especially if you're from northbrook
right if i find your tax
and you're from north bergen
i do not right right right
i don't get text
i won't get text yeah unless you call me
and say joey i'm sending you a text
message i won't get the text for three
or four days and by that time i don't
even look i just erase it because
anybody who's close to me
knows if you text me
i know that i know that when you you're
not so if i get a text from you yeah
there's numbers or like for four days
later they tell me i found something i
forget what area code it was i love
these people that just talk to you on
the text right and they don't even tell
you who they are they identify
themselves like i'm not going to recall
you back anyway
but it's just your text messages when i
find like 26 of them at one shot
that's when i get them when i get like
30 to one shot and i just press edit all
of them you get rid of all of them yeah
i don't even read it see i always feel
like if it well listen there's a time
there's certainly a time and a place for
it you know there's no time in the place
for my world is in your world it's not
not even close yeah
like i don't ever want to text myself
because if it's important the chances of
me getting the slim and none because
your stupidity call a [ __ ] right
if you want somebody to know something
call that [ __ ] i don't play with
text i don't want good for you that's
good i don't want them i don't
especially
when it comes to business
is that right yeah especially how about
how about if you text me for business
yeah i won't do business with you
there you go i don't want to do business
with you
i don't want to do business with you you
got to pick up the phone yeah i don't
give a [ __ ] if you're 10
or 80. i don't know
ashley we laugh our asses off we laugh
because if you're my brother you know
not that so i don't really give a [ __ ]
if you text me it's because you're not
close to me so i don't right right i
don't really my agents know not to text
me
anybody that's close to me and the
industry knows
do not text him because you're not going
to get a reply he's not even going to
get it he's right yeah
because i'm not into him i don't have to
put my glasses on and re and you know
that and then the other thing when i was
getting them when i do get a text
it's just too annoying
it's just too annoying well you know
what happens is what time five what time
is the nick game 6 30 what time we're
meeting at hash ways eight that's good
i can live with that one
i can live with that one but the short
stories
and the no no no no no no no the 92 all
night long no no no no no you got one
good text and i got one good answer and
after that there's no more [ __ ]
texting i'm not going to sit here typing
a short [ __ ] story because you don't
want to talk on the phone so you open
the door to that if you go with one i
hear you because then it it may never
end that's why i said no no no i'm not
doing that i feel like if
it's there are time sensitive things i
love it i think it's a great place for
it but
i do feel i agree with you that there
are things that if like if we're friends
you're gonna call it's important enough
and don't expect like an email like that
i'm you know like you get people that
are gonna email you email me yeah
that's it that's another thing like all
of a sudden i'm obligated to email you
back because you were too lazy to pick
up the phone and call me if it's that
important
it's so weird how if you allow that game
that game will happen
you know it's just like basketball yeah
you let them fast
people
hey can you come on the show to talk
about
the playoffs that's right
but i'll respond to those because those
are people i'm friends who have a
relationship with i'm gonna do that but
you don't like that no i don't want a
text message
whatsoever on my phone when you text me
you're telling me you're not close right
you don't know not to call me sorry i
don't want to do business again it's the
weirdest thing when i was a young
guy i walked into mr biggs and north
bergen they had one in hoboken i went to
north bergen oh he's talking about
biggies no mister babies john benders
and the band okay okay and uh
one of the biggest lessons i learned was
i walked in there when i knew the family
so i could walk in there and say let me
get a hero and then give me whatever the
[ __ ] i want yeah
and one day i was hanging out you know
wiping tables down i was always very
grateful if you gave me a sandwich i'd
wipe the table down and throw the
garbage out or whatever
and uh i said how come you're always
here jimmy whenever i come here you're
always [ __ ] here get help
he goes i'm looking for help in fact he
picked up like a handful of applications
and he threw him down and he goes i got
help but i'm not going to hide on these
people like why not it's just a [ __ ]
i was like a kid yeah i thought you
could just hire people i didn't know how
to check references
and there used to be a box in those days
in the 70s 80s and 90s there used to be
a box on applications and instead of you
do not answer the questions in this box
unless there's a checkup on top
it's that easy unless there's a check up
on top don't answer these questions
so people would fill out those questions
he wouldn't hire him
because they couldn't listen they don't
pay attention to the deal they don't pay
attention to the details and i always
listen to what he said he goes i treat
my life like this if you don't fall
under a certain accountant i'm not wrong
so when you're texting me you're telling
me that you don't even know yeah yeah
because if i especially north bergen
people when i get a text from somebody
from north bergen
i don't reply to them yeah they should
be ashamed of themselves yeah they were
raised better
they were raised better you know they
hit me up like tickets or something i
won't call them back
call me dog especially people i know 30
40 years old
there was somebody
i called from north bergen about three
weeks ago
and for some reason i haven't talked to
this guy in a year because of his text
messages really
he never stops yeah there's times i call
him
and he'll text me back
i could see you texting
yeah that really gets yeah that's that
really gets me that means i won't be
talking to you for another year
right and finally the other day he
called and he goes dog i've been texting
you for a year i haven't gotten one of
them right really nope next time call
yeah
that's it i i know you 50 [ __ ] years
i did drugs with you we did a thousand
things together no i didn't get one of
them oh no i don't get nothing you know
me i haven't gotten anything in use the
only text he ever sends is pictures of
food whenever he goes back to new jersey
i get like randomly like four pictures
and you're you're headed back well
you're gonna be on the island right
it'll be on the island so i will not
this weekend next weekend yeah i won't
[ __ ] go to north america not even a
[ __ ] culvert yeah that's like a
different world if you're going on the
island yeah yeah it's june
oh yeah i mean forget it yeah
yeah they offered me they offered me the
theater
the paramount theater long island
like next weekend
friday night at eight o'clock i was like
are you people [ __ ]
are you people [ __ ]
give me saturday but i ain't involved
with no friday [ __ ] you because
everybody's going down the shore
island's busy on friday nights
everybody's going oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
one o'clock
you're dead you're dead
it's it's seven hours or something
somebody was telling me one time on a
friday it's insanity yeah it's crazy i
don't need to go to northbrook i don't
want nobody coming over people can come
see you you're going three thousand
miles you're gonna be out on the island
no no i told i told timmy holloway
yesterday forget it and somebody else
last week don't even come please i don't
want to say nobody this is my weekend to
relax
i'll be in north bergen july 29th at
uh was that right government to morgana
oh yeah yeah
we'll be there perfect that's perfect
that's where that works
until the first time i don't want to see
nobody yeah i don't want to see nobody i
don't want to go to north berlin i don't
want nobody from north bergen coming up
to long island i want to be left to [ __ ]
alone this weekend you know me doug
what's up lee i don't know what i'm more
higher on the stars or the mold i think
the mold might have the mold is [ __ ]
tremendous here you might have just
created your whole new brand a brand new
edible you have to like it like
when you let cheese get moldy maybe
maybe there's like some hidden secret
maybe like the thc intensifies i had a
taste of a weird taste in my mouth
before like i sucked the [ __ ] like a
moldy dick
but
after and 10 [ __ ] bang hits i'm all
right now
now what uh tell these people what you
do the sports report nine yeah so you
know what because i do uh we do
uh two sports updates 26 and 56 after
the hour 5 a.m to 9 00 a.m pacific time
on kfbk which is a you know uh an iheart
radio station based in sacramento so
it's just you know your basic like wins
you know they do the wheel news
traffic weather business sports you know
rinse and repeat and then during the
basketball season i'll work for you know
a couple of different entities as it
primarily is an analyst uh for games
like whether it's the mountain west
conference like unlv or san diego state
or
colorado state boise state bouncing
around
doing those games also the big west
conference you know from long beach
state to
fullerton to
you know riverside santa barbara uh
then this season i worked a little bit
purdue in indiana on uh national radio
station
yeah yeah so they fly out there they put
you up and then uh
yeah so it's like it's a little bit of a
hodgepodge i'll do a lot of nba stuff uh
uh ad hoc stuff like it whether it's the
clippers pre-game show or you know like
just sports talk throughout the country
on you know the nba and what's going on
and some of it on the sacramento kings i
spent a year with uh what's now nbc nbc
sports bay area on the kings pre and
post game show so it's kind of like a
hodgepodge of uh
of stuff so it's fun it's not unlike
being on the corner at uh at hash ways
talking sports right i mean just
breaking it down breaking down the
knicks and the nets or
the mets of the yankees so it's a great
job and it's kind of fun too because
you know what what it's
listen it's about learning about the
game the people that you meet along the
way there's always so much to learn it's
so much fun and also in this job you
can't you know like
coaching is tough because
you know you got a million
responsibilities and it's high turnover
and people some are going to like you
some are going to be unhappy because
you're not getting playing time or
whatever it may be you got to deal with
the media there's a lot of demands
alumni if you're a college coach
recruiting alumni administration student
body community you know there's a lot a
lot to carry so as an analyst it's like
it's it's tremendous you're a guest at
shoot around a day of the game uh you're
a guest in that arena wherever the game
is you're a guest
on that network that platform and and
you're a guest in somebody's living room
so it's like a lot of fun
uh
but you don't win or lose at the end of
the day but you don't have
uh
you you also don't have people
mad at you either so it's kind of like a
great job it's a lot of it's a lot of
fun just being around the game and
learning and it's fascinating what's
going on what and how it's changed and
how it's evolved and all that stuff so
that kind of keeps me going and really
energized and passionate about it
because you can
you know look at you be brown he's going
strong at 83. there's no stopping them
and you're you're learning along the way
as the thing involves is great
like i totally once life got real i i
don't watch that much sports anymore
once life started getting real
i lost it i would watch five minutes of
[ __ ]
do you watch the end the games coco like
well you watch the finals and like and
watch a couple minutes i watched the
finals monday night
they
yeah it doesn't didn't didn't stir you
at all didn't you know
you get emotional when you've seen teams
win like do you ever get emotional when
you see like you know uh durant and his
mom or or curry and his family or
i don't give a [ __ ] yeah yeah they uh
they seem like a yankee team to me
the warriors golden state seems like a
yankee team to me
but they were terrible just a few years
ago like when i was following basketball
when the celtics were pretty good the
warriors were like the laughing stuff
yeah they were booing like
off the field
for 20 years so i'm really proud about
that i just don't know i just uh no it's
fair enough i mean i don't have anything
i don't have any what's that expression
i don't have a dog you don't have a dog
in the fight yeah yeah yeah
it's like uh
college moves too fast i mean i i know
kylie irving is yeah bad [ __ ]
and i know who
the kid from golden state is i know some
of the players i know the kids from
north bergen
oh kyle anderson yeah without the spurs
uh you know [ __ ] like that but i
couldn't tell you anything about it yeah
football
i watched the last couple playoff games
the white supremacy man it's the best
quarterback the last 20 years it don't
matter ain't nobody better than tom
brady yeah he's white supremacy man yeah
yeah he's he's the raise he's the only
white person that's really entitled that
deserves to be entitled the rest of
white america could suck my dick
when they do what he could do dump a
pregnant chick and [ __ ] win five
super bowls then come see me all right
just dumping the pregnant chick alone
tells me you give a [ __ ] about
catholicism and your last name is brady
now you're gonna win five super bowls to
boot or whatever he's won nineteen
who gives a [ __ ] ain't nobody better
five four seven yeah montana's thinking
making a comeback this together he's
[ __ ] tormenting people if they [ __ ]
with him again he might win this year
too it's unbelievable he might win this
year too if they [ __ ] with him again he
might just go you know what i'll drop
the first four game because the
quarterbacks they have under him are
savages yeah garoppolo is pretty good
yeah just to be under him and to watch
what did he do with garoppolo last year
they survived right were they three in
one with him well he uh before brady
came back he got hurt i think after the
second game so they brought uh jacoby
percentage
and then he won
yeah
you're learning
so much behind me it's like sitting
behind obviously it's like set mine
julius irving for four years yeah it's
like just sitting there and being his
body double guarding him learning all
those moves you see the thing is you
know what
listen if you think about basketball
right i could sum it up
it's ball you man
hit sh that's how you defend ball you
man
shot goes up hit find go get it right
offensively it's pace and space it's
pick and roll
pass and screen away i mean
in other words what i'm trying to say is
it's not complicated at all it really
isn't and and all of this like
even though there's like all the
analytics now and what have you this
obfuscation you know taking the simple
and making it complex and then you've
got this you know blogger demagoguery
where you know the pendulum swings on
you know virtually every possession
people are going bananas every you know
every game's life or death they don't
realize that you know like it's so funny
you see how about these reporters like
the questions they ask it's like
ridiculous
they ask uh lebron he's down two zip
they're going back to cle going back to
cleveland he's like hey do you think
that you have to protect home court
it's like of course you've got to
protect it are you a smart guy what
happens if we don't protect home quote
then some somebody asked doc rivers uh
chris paul scored and then utah came
down and scored to beat them you know
and they're down one and somebody asked
did did uh
did uh chris paul score too soon i mean
i could go on and on with these these
crazy questions but anyway my point is
you know
it's just interesting to watch because
the game itself is not complicated at
all but it's about
you know getting these guys ultra
talented basically independent
contractors getting them to buy in and
to incorporate your game plan into what
you want you see somebody like the
warriors do it and the spurs have been
doing it quietly almost like in a boring
way to do it you know the spurs have
kept opponents under a hundred points
for like 20 years
and we have never we have the last nba
champion that was
out of the top 10 in defensive rating
was like the 01 lakers
but it's just interesting but to your
point though it's true it's hard to keep
up with it because the free agency guys
like
baseball they're all over the place
they're all over the place i couldn't
once i followed sports as far as i could
until life kicked in
once my life kicked in
i couldn't sit there no more billy
sit yeah yeah i got something to do
in the back of my mind i'm there ten
minutes and i go okay
there's gotta be something yeah i could
be doing it better myself
so that was what happened i couldn't uh
i i still remember you matured that's it
you know what like no because i remember
still
and it was even before i got locked up
like i had given up sports like that
yeah i was living in denver and
everybody was john l way crazy right oh
yeah people were always i was working
right i didn't you're grinding [ __ ] you
down they would go what don't you want
you're interested and i go i'm an adult
right there's something that has to come
first if i have the
the luxury you know
i was taking classes and i would go wait
a second i'm going to watch four hours
of football i got to study for them so
i'm giving up the gameplay i'm going
home
the season's over no no no no no i know
i'm just what happened to me this is
yeah yeah that's what personally
happened to me
you know and then i gotta i went i got
locked up
and that became even higher
like i said what am i doing much
imaginable right there's gonna be
something i could be [ __ ] doing you
know something
so now i'll tell lee i watch sports for
15 minutes here
eight minutes here i want to dodge a
game that god awful to watch
i can't watch it baseball it's just too
slow for me anymore yeah i like
september so i'll wait till september
football you know if uh if i'm home on a
sunday night and the red sox are playing
the yankees i'm watching anything on
both of them i let them both go up yeah
that's enough for me but to sit there
for four innings five innings i could
write a joke guy yeah i got lights to
turn on
i got there's always something yeah you
could do a push-up
exercise yeah exactly yeah that's the
other thing it's hey [ __ ] hours and
you've got potato chips in your [ __ ]
mouth and pizzas and [ __ ] wings you
know and it's sunday yeah so you're
gonna wake up monday feeling like that
and this is the way like even though i'm
a fat [ __ ] like i always felt like this
like i'm like i'm gonna go over there
for what they have potato chips and that
onion dip right
in the sour cream dip it was just i
don't know what it was see now i got
away from it when my kids were young
right i got away from it you had to yeah
because i mean you could you could watch
it the thing that saved you today
is that
you could tape things yeah exactly [ __ ]
you
i'm gonna be one of those [ __ ]
please don't tell me did you watch the
game don't tell me please no no no no no
it's impossible now i hate all this yeah
yeah i hate all that i used to try to do
that with the patriots but i can't i had
to stop because you'd always call me and
tell me how tom brady was doing yeah i'm
gonna tape it and watch it later tonight
when then when somebody tells you like i
wasted the tape right
ways to the tape you know what i'm
saying i don't wanna watch it now unless
somebody goes it was a spectacular game
right right like with the soup bowl this
year they were losing twenty thousand
points yeah i went in the room and wrote
for a little while right but that's what
i'll do yeah like if it's something i
wanna watch
i sacrifice a little
there you go yeah you got to give a
little but i used to get on lee lee
you're 20 something years old i'm 20
something years old i'm getting my dick
sucked i'm not gonna sit there with
eight idiots in a ball
[Laughter]
yeah but you're a dumb [ __ ] during the
week i don't want to sit with you on a
sunday it's all [ __ ] day
yeah yeah yeah billy i grew up at the
garden
sure really yeah
billy i went to three
julius serving christmas games at the
garden
once with chuck mcbreen when julius on
christmas day i'm one of those [ __ ]
okay
i i took a bus to see moses malone with
the houston rockets when the nets play
that piscataway this is
the rack okay there's a surprise about
that you had to take a bus to the port
authority and switch buses so we didn't
get home till two in the morning meet
chuck mcbreen to see moses malone at
houston when he was 20 20 and 20 every
night 20 rebounds 20 points and 20
smacks to the face
somebody got beat up i did [ __ ] i went
this i went to i drove to philadelphia
to see the sixes i drove to uniondale to
see the nets as a kid right i did
everything yeah yeah i went to see i was
there when pete rose beat up bud
howellson i went you were at that game
yeah i went to maybe 10 [ __ ] ranger
games i went to maybe two islander games
you know i went to just one jet game i
never liked the jets to see about that
but i went to i don't know how many
countless giant games how many [ __ ]
general games that i go to how many
general games that i [ __ ] go to you
know i'm saying in 90 degree weather in
the inside so for me to admit this to
you as a sports guy i mean
i don't know my life changes the life i
totally gave it was the weirdest thing
and i gambled for a while and once i
left northbrook and i said you know what
i'll never gamble again and now
i totally gamble on this he won't
because he's got a [ __ ] you know yeah
so he won't bet and he'll come to me and
say how did you know come on that's what
we grew up in now i see all the moves
and then once you see a team you know
how they're tailored you start looking
at their line
and you see how they start [ __ ]
killing people whenever brady has a high
line that means it's going to shut the
lights out on you that means your
world's going to come through you know
saying like you're done
but i just uh
yeah i just do it because you know
obviously my job
yeah yeah and a [ __ ] job and it and
it's for me it just it's become fun
again like for a while i was like you're
right i kept one eye on it running
around with the kids but uh but i could
totally see that though because there's
a lot there's a lot
there there are so many demands on your
time and it disappoints me
is that right american
sure it disappoints me
but it disappoints me in the same way
i'm disappointed by that
okay i'm not looking for a handout billy
but there's not a situation
where i could come over here and go
billy what are you doing nothing
let's get the [ __ ] out of here let's go
see a [ __ ] lake again
and we go down there me and you go over
to the place and we throw a snake down
our throat
and we grab lee and we smoke a number
with lee and then we walk over you know
what
you want to charge me 65 and take it to
the lakers
i'm all in
but i can't give you 185 for the top
shelf right right right i gotta sit up
there with angels
i gotta sit up there all the way up at
the top for 185 i can't do it yeah i
can't do it yeah sure no i guess julia's
serving for 15. right yeah 12 50. i saw
julius serving on christmas day you want
to bother me yeah with 185 to see these
pathetic schmucks went up and down it
breaks my heart that i don't go to 15
dodging games a year i grew up at chase
stadium in cuba right yeah sure but you
know what i don't like what they're
doing to the american public
a family of four has to pay 50 dollars
to park or if they want to save the 50
they gotta take a train like
like [ __ ] uh yugoslavians on the
fourth go suck my dick that's why i'm a
little yeah that's a good point i think
the money situation the sports killed me
that i just got when i first moved here
i go to costco
and i get two tickets for the dodgers
two hot dogs two sodas and two pretzels
and parking for fifty dollars at costco
yeah
and you go there and it's like a halfway
empty game and they'll upgrade you and
me and you go we say listen i got four
good endings in me right right i got
four innings before i look you can go we
gotta get the [ __ ] out of here metzer in
town next week by the way yeah that's
great you go there sit with those
[ __ ] knuckleheads
those [ __ ] let's go mets at dodger
stadium then you walk around with a
concussion helmet the rest of your life
with a ball because you want to sit with
a bunch of new yorkers get the [ __ ] out
i'll watch it for three innings and i'm
[ __ ] happy
that's the other thing that people just
became i don't want to go to a [ __ ]
game and get beat up yeah yeah it's
crazy i don't want to wear a manhattan
get beat up or dodger hat this guy goes
with a mexican chick they're going to
kill him one day you know
you know [ __ ] some pekka woods
hanging out with americana you don't
need that in your life either you go or
she goes you can't go together the
dodger games you're gonna get killed
yeah maybe i mean they didn't i think i
don't think they care about it if your
team is not a rival it's a joke
it's a [ __ ] joke dog sucker billy
horinda i'm happy you came on here
tonight my pleasure thank you gentlemen
of the scholar
after 40 [ __ ] years it's still a
pleasure knowing you just to let your
[ __ ] know eighth grade i was 13
i'm 54.
so i got to be knowing him 41 years when
they had first pregnancy
he was a little kid looking at me you're
going to camp with my mother [ __ ] yeah
first off i want to tell you something
whether i'm at jiu-jitsu whether i'm at
the gym
if i'm wearing a nice pair of pants me
undies is always on when i wear jeans i
can't wear me undies the jeans fit a
certain way and they [ __ ] me up but if i
got a nice pair of dress pants on a suit
jiu-jitsu shorts jiu-jitsu
it's tremendous there's no better
underwear than me on these you
understand me there's a reason i've been
telling you about me on these for a few
years now they're simply the softest
most comfortable underwear you'll ever
wear once you try them
you won't want to wear anything else
okay trust me
unless you're naked or something like
that in your swimsuit
every pair of me on these they're
sustainably sourced and made from micro
motor a fabric that's three times softer
than cotton i told you guys this if
you're used to buying packs of
uncomfortable boring underwear that only
come in white gray black and maybe a tan
that
me undies will change everything okay
because my undies comes in all kinds of
colors patterns and they release a new
limited edition pattern each month that
always sells out this month it's the
rainbow confetti called celebrate try me
undies today go get the celebrate
pattern before they're all gone at
meundies.com slash joey and i'll tell
you what i'm gonna do i'm gonna save you
20 hours and you're off your first pair
you have to feel yourself you have to
feel them for yourself to see why me
undies
has sold over five million pairs to date
and if you don't love your first prayer
me undies
they're free they're on the house so do
me a favor get 20 off your first player
plus free shipping at meundies.com
joey right now i'm telling you
these are the most something these are
the softest most comfortable underwear
you'll ever wear if you wear them i'll
tell you what happens it'll keep the
sweat down you're not even gonna believe
the things beyond these done it keeps
your nutsack nice and clean nice and
warm and they smell beautiful that's why
this month they got the confetti they
got the whole rainbow confetti print
called celebrate do me a favor go get
the celebrate pattern before they're all
gone right now at meundies.com joey and
you'll save 20 off your first pair you
understand me right now meundies.com
joey one more time meundies.com joey
speaking underwear before you put your
underwear on you want to be clean and
refreshed
that's where hello tushie comes in
what's hello tushie joey hello tushy is
a portable bidet that fits on your
toilet
to make your muffler smell and feel
tremendous you understand me the sun is
coming you're walking around all day
long you get that humidity in your ass
you get that swamp ass next thing you
know you get hemorrhoids next thing
you'll get brown stains on your
underwear you're an adult you don't need
that [ __ ] end it right now
go to hellotushy.com right now and press
in
hellotushy.com church all right
impressing what hello tushie.com church
you don't have to press and dick joey
you know why because hello tushy is the
way to go
i don't know if you know what a bidet is
if you know whatever day works it's like
having a mission in the toilet it just
spits at your little [ __ ] you
understand me you know what that's like
just sitting there getting a little
water up your little monkey or your
little [ __ ] and if you're a guy you
can sit back a little bit you pull the
skin back and you can just wash off that
helmet sometimes you get like do's and
little pieces of cotton in there and
stuff like that no more
no more and ladies you don't have to
have that little sweaty monkey if you
don't need to listen as men we like when
your monkey's a little sweaty
but if you don't like it if you don't
like that little onion [ __ ] it
hello tushy comes in and they'll clean
that monkey that muffler or that helmet
spotless clean and if you shift to the
right or left you get the creases in
between your nut sack and that helps out
too because that's where the mold
develops and that's where the real
problem's coming so do yourself a favor
look at yourself in the mirror and say
from now on i'm going to have a clean
ass oh why because hellotushy.com is
going to get it there and you know what
it doesn't stop now
father's day is coming you got those
sunday you could order it and probably
get it speed delivered to your dad by
sunday by sunday night you asked your
dad's [ __ ] would be tip top magoo
shiny like it was
when he first came out of your
grandmother's monkey so do me a favor
get on hellotushi.com
right now and press in hellotushy.com
church boom and get percent off
delivered right to your house all right
hello she's a tremendous product and if
you don't if it breaks something you got
a 90 day money back guarantee which
you'll never want once you get a
hellotissue.com today i guarantee you'll
get a very goddamn bat from the house
keep your [ __ ] clean it's a whole new
year it's a whole new set of priorities
go to hellotushy.com
right now
beside that i love you [ __ ]
thank you i want to thank billy i want
to thank my man lisa don't forget
tomorrow night the ice house well
tonight when you get this it's thursday
night the ice house and next friday and
saturday
governors up in the levee town
[ __ ]
stay black uncle joey loves you see you
next week
[Music]